[Music]  hey I'm for Fred Rogers in here  it's a beautiful day in this  neighborhood a beautiful day for a  neighbor would you be mine could you be  mine  please about you be my neighbor  hello neighbor mr. Rogers I'm here to  interview you it is so nice to meet you  okay full filing mr. Rogers Lloyd please  don't ruin my childhood this piece will  be for an issue about heroes do you  consider yourself a hero  we are trying to give the world positive  ways of dealing with feelings  now like what  there are many things you can do  you could play all the lowest keys on a  pin at the same time  [Music]  you love broken people  okay  sometimes we have to ask for that  and that's okay  I think the best thing we can do is to  let people know  that each one of them is preface  [Music]  hey mr. Rogers it's a beautiful  neighborhood beautiful day per neighbor  please watch me my neighbor was  wonderful  [Music]